[Music]
i have to ask you about this ad that you
did uh and it caused my brain to catch
on fire
uh i was on the internet recently and i
see that uh bar rafaeli has this ad that
she did for this line of underwear yes
uh your line of underwear and i thought
well i'll check out the cnn homepage in
a minute but first things first
and i clicked on this ad and then my
mind caught on fire yeah smoke came out
my ears and i'd like to show this ad
right now this is you playing tennis uh
in your underwear let's take a look
people only see you playing tennis in
your underpants
but i tell you what they don't know
how much pressure you're under
it's a very good ad you know we were
thinking what people like to do in their
underwear yeah and and then we were like
okay i guess play tennis yeah play
tennis it's a fantastic ad it is uh
everybody is talking about that ad i'm
curious the underwear for women is very
beautiful um what do you
like men to wear what kind of underwear
would you like to see do you like to see
a man or what is underwear what does a
man's underwear tell you about that man
how about that
well
let's uh
i think it tells you a lot when a man
wears women's underwear that i don't
need to explain that right
it's comfortable i will say in defense
yeah women's underwear is much more
comfortable right um
i think
you know i noticed that the guys that
have the reputation of being
large
are um the ones that like the very loose
underwear
yes and yes yeah i don't what are you
wearing by the way i'm wearing very
loose underwear
[Applause]
i'm so glad you told me the correct
answer before you asked me
uh yeah no i like it very loose i like
there to be there needs to be a lot of
room
[Applause]
did you make mensa to wear as well we
make women's we make men's we make tank
tops and
t-shirts could i get some of your men's
if you get me some of your men's
underwear i will wear it i actually
wanted to get you some and then i know
you asked for a large or extra large in
the production set extra small i wasn't
sure
[Applause]
i'm starting on the wrong foot i think
i'm starting on this those people are so
fired right now
you get me your underwear i will wear it
here on the air i swear to you and i
won't and i will talk about every now
and then park railroad um
congratulations barbara felix such a
treat having you on the show thanks so
much for being here